tall public et pour les français mr
sylla par l'état madame dominique
nachury merci merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre l'éducation nationale
mercredi dernier
mon collègue patrick hetzel évoqué la
fuite des élèves vers l'enseignement
privé et vous avez fui le fond de sa
question
comme toujours vous caricaturez les
propos de la droite et nier la réalité
madame la ministre plus modestement si
vous écoutiez les parents des collégiens
ou futurs collégiens à lyon à
villeurbanne ou partout ailleurs ils
vous éclairer sur les raisons de ce
choix
madame la ministre vous répéter que
votre réforme du collège vise à
l'amélioration des apprentissages ya la
réussite de tous mais les parents liste
ou entendent suppression du latin du
grec suppression des classes bilangues
26 heures pour tous
suppression d'heures de cours discipline
est pour un enseignement
interdisciplinaire bien difficile à
appréhender pour eux ce ne sont que des
moins il le traduisent ainsi réduction
des exigences perte de chance de
réussite ultérieure nivellement par le
bas
et sur ce point l'enseignement privé les
rassure
de plus votre communication sur la
réforme du collège centrée sur les
élèves en difficulté en quelque sorte
qualifier l'ensemble elle exclut la
personnalisation de l'enseignement pour
tous les élèves
sur ce point aussi l'enseignement privé
rassure les parents
madame la ministre les mots ne peuvent
pas contredire les faits les postures ne
suffisent pas à convaincre les parents
ont des attentes concrètes et des
ambitions légitimes pour leurs enfants
les prendrez-vous enfin en considération
je veux remercier la parole est à madame
najat vallaud belkacem ministre de
l'éducation nationale de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche
pardon je cherchais merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés madame la députée dominique
nachury vous avez rappelé que cette
question n'a en effet déjà été posée que
j'ai apporté une réponse rappelant
notamment que le flux d'élèves du public
vers le privé à la rentrée 2016 était de
0,2 pour cent et qu'il faut savoir
raison garder mais pour autant vous fait
un constat que nous partageons tout cela
fait en effet vingt ans maintenant que
des parents choisissent de mettre leurs
enfants dans le privé en particulier
dans un certain nombre de territoires
dans lesquels l'enseignement public n'a
pas bonne réputation et singulièrement
au collège c'est précisément pour
laquelle la réforme la raison pour
laquelle la réforme du collège a été
conduite pour améliorer le niveau dans
les collèges publics comme privés
d'ailleurs puisque je le rappelle à
nouveau cette réforme du collège
s'applique également dans les collèges
privés exactement dans les mêmes termes
à la forme du collège qui prévoit
notamment un accompagnement personnalisé
que vous venez d'appeler de vos voeux je
vous invite à regarder ce qu'il ya dans
cette réforme désormais en vigueur un
accompagnement personnalisé qui
s'adresse à tous les élèves qu'il soit
en difficulté ou qu'ils soient plus en
avance pour les faire progresser
chacun à leur rythme pardonnez-nous
madame la députée nachury de nous
intéresser en effet aux élèves en
difficulté pour une raison simple c'est
que ce que nous disent tous les
classements pisa que vous aimez tant
commenté c'est que le problème de notre
système scolaire au fond ce ne sont pas
ces élèves qui réussissent cela
réussissent très bien tant mieux pour
eux c'est les élèves en difficulté qu'on
ne s'est pas rattrapé à temps avec les
réformes que nous avons conduite pendant
ce quinquennat on saura rattraper les
élèves à temps j'en viens maintenant au
privé parce qu'il y est une question qui
nous intéresse surtout les bancs c'est
la façon dont le privé peut s'associer à
nos efforts pour davantage de mixité
sociale au collège et je veux dire ici
que dans le cadre des expérimentations
que j'ai mise en oeuvre je ne me
souviens pas qu'elle l'ait été avant moi
et bien les établissements privés sont
aussi engagés dans la démarche preuve en
est qu'à la rentrée 2010 est j'ai vues
supplémentaires pour les établissements
à blanc